battery's low
yeah
plug it in
fair yep
[Music]
i just wish it was
faster yeah
plug it in
[Music]
hey hey what's up mkbhd here and this
lenovo legion dual 2 is already the
fastest most powerful phone i've ever
used but there's so much more to a phone
than just pure speed and you know you
know those people who like every couple
weeks sort of make their way around
headlines and youtube comments
saying phones are getting boring again
and everything looks the same and
there's no innovation
anymore this one's for you so this is
one of the weirdest phones i've ever
seen and it tries a bunch of new things
and they're not necessarily always
fantastic ideas but sometimes you got to
try a bunch of weird stuff to land on a
great idea so i'm just here to point the
camera at the thing and show you what
they've tried
so as you can probably tell from the
name and the general aesthetic it's a
gaming phone and they are not shy about
it so you know how some of the gaming
phones lately started off pretty
aggressive but then have slowly started
to get a little softer at least
aesthetically not this one
not this one this one
barely really even looks like a phone at
all it honestly looks more just kind of
like a mobile game console that
happens to make phone calls and send
texts take pictures so
the whole thing is laid out horizontally
like this because
you know any
real games on your phone are going to be
the horizontal ones and so all the
components inside are laid out
horizontally now when i tell you this
phone has a 5500 milliamp hour battery
you might be wondering where could you
fit that in a phone this shape but that
battery is split between the left side
and the right side of the phone
literally so 2 750 milliamp hours on the
right and 27.50 on the left and actually
think this is a great idea it has
multiple benefits first of all the sides
of the phone where your fingers usually
are actually stay cooler to the touch
because of all the hot components that
require cooling all being lined up in
the middle the weight distribution is
also now perfectly even and that lets
them focus all the cooling on just that
smaller portion just the middle of the
phone and that's exactly what they do so
you can see they gave it a whole turbine
fan that happens to actually light up if
you want it to you know gamery stuff is
next to the rgb logo on the back and
there's a vent on each side to exhaust
the hot air from the cpu gpu motherboard
ram etc there also doesn't have to be a
separate camera bump because the cameras
are in the middle too
i'm telling you nothing about this phone
is conventional so you might remember
pretty recently the whole dual battery
turbo charging thing in some other
phones like vook charging and all that
oneplus did it and that would be
literally because they'd have a split
battery inside the phone so phones with
this tech could charge at 50 watts for
example because both batteries would
charge in parallel at 25 watts each
this phone
kind of takes it to a hilarious extreme
there are two usbc ports on the phone
and it comes with this
90 watt charging brick
with
two usbc ports
on the brick and if you plug in the two
included usb cables from the box into
both of those usbc ports and plug in
both of the usb ports on the phone one
on the bottom one on the side
you can charge this thing at 90 watts
which is crazy fast you can get 50
charge from dead in 13 minutes or
literally go zero to a hundred and half
an hour which is very impressive for a
battery this big but it's also kind of
hilarious seeing your phone plugged in
twice and it might be a little bit of a
hassle to carry this heavy brick and two
charging cables everywhere you go
but the satisfaction of plugging in both
ports on the phone and seeing the
animation light up and the battery
percentage just starting to jump up
yeah i'd say that's worth it plus this
is a phone with a lot of other well
thought out battery options so they
offer bypass charging so you can just
power it from a cable instead of just
the battery to avoid heat like we saw
with the rog phone five also there's all
kinds of charging limiters to preserve
long-term battery health it's a nice
trend to see the stuff more baked in you
can of course also always just plug in
with one port like any other lame phone
with only one charging port but of
course you're only going to get 45 watts
that way you know but hey being able to
plug in from the side is way more
comfortable if you're gaming so that's
why the gaming phones do that love it
but man this phone has the works as far
as hardware goes as you'd expect dual
front-facing speakers in this sort of
aggressive triangular shape that gets
very loud a huge 6.92 inch 144 hertz
1080p oled display up front with a
ridiculous
720 hertz touch sampling rate and 1300
nits peak brightness
there's a ton of touch sensitive
remappable buttons on the sides and the
back of this thing so for gaming it's
got everything you need and to drive all
this you've got the snapdragon triple
eight up to half a terabyte of fast
storage and up to 18 gigs of ram so this
is the most maxed out phone on paper
again and it definitely translates to
responsiveness there's no question about
that it's the snappiest phone i've ever
laid hands on even when you're not
gaming just flipping around the ui
multitasking etc but you know what
that's that's maybe the least important
thing about a phone like this right it's
a gaming phone
we want to know how it games okay
now
let's be real for a second when it comes
to mobile gaming i would consider myself
a bit of a casual i think that's a fair
a fair description like i've reviewed
gaming phones before but
i don't play the most intensive games
it's kind of like reviewing a supercar
without taking it to the track like you
get a better idea of what it's like to
live with sure but it leaves out a
pretty big reason why you'd get a car
like that so i could tell you from my
extremely casual gaming use that this
phone absolutely crushes everything as
you'd expect it's actually overkill
usually i don't get any functional
advantage from a 720hz touch refresh
rate when i'm playing among us like it's
really more than enough but even when
you're playing a heavier game like
asphalt 9 you can start to feel the
combined advantages of everything this
phone does start to come to life the
high refresh rate and the screen look
incredible and super sharp and immersive
of course the super high touch sample
rate is great for making quick cuts and
moves in the car but also the
customizable triggers on the shoulder of
the phone come in handy because now
you're touching the same spot on the
screen over and over again for nitro and
drifting so you can just map those to
the shoulder triggers so that's really
nice to never have to block the screen
with my fingers
and there's way more than i'd ever need
this phone has four ultrasonic shoulder
keys with a hertz touch sample refresh
each
and
two more rear capacitive touch points
plus you've got two more force touch
spots on either side of the display so
obviously the games i played don't need
all that but if you do you've got all
these extra keys as an option now if
you're playing a game like asphalt 9
after a while pretty much any phone is
going to start to get pretty warm now
the outside of this phone
actually legit stayed a little bit
cooler on the outsides where my fingers
are versus the middle which got warmer
and spun up the fan and kept performance
high that is an actual real measurable
benefit that i felt not just a gimmick
and then something you also quickly
notice and i'll just have to describe it
to you because it's kind of hard to show
it on video this phone has two haptic
motors one linear haptic motor on each
side of the phone
and they combine
to make a really strong
thumpy
punchy vibration motor it is
is really impressive i'm gonna i'm gonna
say it's the most strong and impressive
vibration i felt in any phone i don't
think any other phone has two
uh and so it's awesome one gaming any
sort of like light interaction footsteps
scraping by something every gunfire
really feels strong on this phone i keep
calling it a phone but on this mobile
gaming console but also when you do just
use it like a phone like typing on the
keyboard
an alarm clock like everything you'd
expect to to vibrate it is very strong
but hey like i said
i'm just a casual so i handed this phone
to andrew resident gaming enthusiasts
here at the studio but also a long time
pub g player handed him this phone with
pub g mobile on it and not exaggerating
his first game he methodically sort of
learns the mechanics through the first
few minutes he's getting some kills
picking up ammo and supplies the circle
starts shrinking other people start
dying and he starts getting a few more
kills the fans start spinning up as the
phone starts to hum along and keep those
frames up and sure enough
seven kills later he wins the game his
first game chicken dinner made it look
easy now i'm not saying this phone is
the reason why he won
but that is pretty impressive now when
you're in a game and you just want to
toggle a setting or something like that
real quick you can just swipe down from
the top and then you have a bunch of
quickly accessible settings mostly to do
with gaming your volume brightness
signal strength and your ping is sitting
there and then your cpu and gpu clock
speed just for kicks but also with a
rampage button to literally max out the
clock speeds to keep those frames up at
all costs and there's also the bypass
charge toggle if you want to turn that
on and you're plugged in and there's
also something here you can see called
stream mode all right you ready for this
this is one last gimmick i promise this
is a last crazy thing the selfie
camera is uh
is inside
the power button
of course so that's a 44 megapixel
motorized live stream ready selfie
camera that's literally oriented
horizontally all the time because its
primary purpose
is to be your webcam if you want to
stream your games directly to twitch or
youtube that's right the phone is not
only ready to max out your games but
it's ready to broadcast your games with
that extremely average quality selfie
camera i'd expect nothing less also it's
really loud to open and close
anyway uh this is amazing there's
honestly no other phone i've ever used
that's quite like this and it's so weird
to keep saying that it's a phone just
because it feels like the phone
functionality
in this
is such an afterthought it happens to do
other things like do you even care about
the camera quality in a phone like this
there happens to be a 64 megapixel
primary camera on the back that's
literally blocked when you open up the
camera app because the way you normally
hold a phone puts your fingers right
over it
but it happens to pair that with 123
degree ultra wide and collectively they
both take reasonable
acceptable photos and good light this
thing happens to also send text messages
and make phone calls if you really want
it to it can also use the internet and
browse through other apps and it can be
an amazing alarm clock with those huge
haptics and gigantic speakers but all of
that feels like it just happens to be
true at this point this is just it's the
ultimate all-in on
the gaming phone again it's it's not
trying to hide it or be shy about it and
do things like wireless charging or
water resistance it kind of doesn't
matter at this level
it's just a mobile gaming
handheld with cellular so even if it's
not for me
i'm glad they made it i'm glad this
exists and i would i would happily
recommend it to other people i know who
are
much more into mobile gaming
but speaking of that
that's the question i want to ask you
that's that's what i want to leave you
with for this video do any of you
watching this video
actually consider
buying a gaming phone like do any of you
play a game on your phone so much that
you would specifically get a phone
tailored to being better at that
and if so what game are you playing
let me know in the comment section below
if you if you know that guy if you are
that guy either way
that's been it thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
you